hey everybody welcome back to morals and
strapped in for what is probably going
to be the most slow-paced episode in the
history of gaming since even though this
video is sped up twelve times I didn't
really manage to get that much work done
or at least I got a lot of work done
just on a large scale it's not that much
basically what I did is the station a
very basic idea of what's gonna be
around it and a start of the transfer
track but 99% is just gonna be this
station and I expect it to be done with
this in a couple of hours primarily
because that's sort of what I was
planning to do because otherwise I would
run into time issues which I'm doing now
anyway but it just turned out to be a
pretty time-consuming endeavor reason
being I would say is for one something
that just always kind of happens for me
and this might be relatable for quite a
lot of people as well is that I just
kind of start something and feel like I
can finish this in an hour
and I'll just leave it the way that I've
been planning to but while you're
building you just find all of these
different things that you want to add or
you want to do and everything just ends
up taking so much more time and suddenly
it's 5 p.m. and you've wasted an entire
day playing planet coaster and it's
awful and anyway that's beside the point
basically this thing took a lot of time
and it took in a special amount of time
compared to what I'm usually doing since
as you can see I am absolutely going
crazy with making custom everything in
this case since basically I feel for
this kind of theme and I'm going for a
traditional esque Russian theme it's
it's a little bit more romanticized than
that but with this kind of theme the
theme is really in a detail take out the
details of this and it's basically just
any wooden Alpine thing could be
somewhere in Europe could be somewhere
in North America I feel it's really in
the details and the wood carvings in the
shapes of the roofs things like that
where the Russian wooden style sticks
out and that's why this ended up taking
a huge amount of time since basically
everything about this station is made
custom and even unfinished it's a couple
of thousand pieces it's absolutely
ridiculous
and it's a pretty good reason why
a lot of this episode is just detailing
not so much making large-scale pieces or
landscaping anything like that now the
first thing that I was very inspired to
do was the spire of the building well
first and foremost it's the most
important thing for me in the building
itself it's not really what gives it the
moss it's the biggest part of the
building it's just gonna be the roof
over this station but this is really the
the signature iconic part of the
building so I wanted to make sure that I
got this right right away and it's it's
just the simple spire it's somewhat
similar to the spires that we have in
game but I wanted to get a slightly sort
of custom a little bit more steep idea
to it and also wanted to make some
custom dormers ish parts sticking out
here and something that I wanted to try
and do and especially like in in many of
the cases of the roofs that I'm building
here is édouard carvings underneath them
which I'm not exactly getting to just
still working on the ironworks and the
little decorations on top of the roof
which are equally as important I would
say but it's definitely the iron the
wood carvings in like the wood works
which I ended up sinking a lot of time
in now this was just using all of the
different Christmas
well whatever decorations really to put
down different roof items things like
that I I'll definitely be using some of
the Christmas decorations as actual
Christmas decorations but for the most
parts they're just amazing building
pieces that I wanted to experiment with
a lot in this build which a lot of it
comes back in these little roof
decorations they're the smallest things
but these are some of my favorite things
to really be building it's just so much
fun to experiment with them and they
just add that little bit of flair to any
building I often kind of overused them
too I also wanted to place a bit of snow
on the roof because even though I wanted
to keep the amount of snow quite low
kind of make it seem as though you know
this the snow has fallen a couple of
days ago it's still a bit on the trees
and there's still bit on the roofs but
it's not like everything is
100% covered so it's just sort of lying
in heaps on the bottoms of the roofs
we're just kind of normally accumulates
and that also just sort of leaves the
rest of the roof still open for you to
actually see the detail and I hope
that's kind of a nice sort of in-between
option between having too much snow and
just sort of covering all of the details
or not having any snow at all and having
it stick out with the otherwise pretty
snowy environments so here's where I got
into some of the first Woodworks
underneath the roof it's just a fairly
simple bow at this point I don't feel
it's very representative of what all of
the word like work was going to be put
into but it's it's a bunch of different
things firstly I wanted to use the
wooden pillars to actually get some
solid base for these decorations and
then I'm using many of the difference
gingerbread pieces which I'm never using
for Gingerbread but they're absolutely
amazing for any kind of patterns that
you want to use and put onto any kind of
surface or texture especially if you
change the colour they blend into all
kinds of things that you could use them
for so in this case I wanted to use them
for the cornices and decorations
underneath the roof here but also on the
side of this wall over here and it's
just sort of a mock war to see what this
would look like this is basically the
top spire almost finished and I was
going to raise it up a little bit like
getting the composition of a tower like
this right just took a little bit of
trial and error but at some point I just
gave up and decided to work on the rest
of the station so the first thing that I
wanted to head into is the walkway which
takes you from the exits back onto the
paths of the park itself and I guess
there's a sort of a double [ __ ]
function in the sense that you know it's
obviously the exit walkway but I didn't
want to just leave that out there in the
building somewhere and just kind of hide
it so it's this nice way to add
something that comes to the front from
the station and gives it a bit more of a
facade feel which you'll see in a bit
that's why I also wanted to focus a bit
on
adding all of these decorated fences on
the side of the exit pod then I made the
actual big roof and this is pretty much
making a custom scenery set at this
point making a couple of different
custom roofs into a set which is modular
and which you can use to put like put
them into each other and make your own
custom roofs without spending too much
time placing every single object that's
basically wild at this point very rough
sketch of what the roof is going to look
like eventually and after this I wanted
to make the gable pieces with some of
the gable carvings so I went back into
some of these very lights wooden
textured pieces to make the carvings on
the side here I wanted to use the very
light wooden colors by the way to sort
of give the idea that this is a very
newly built building and the wood is all
just still fresh and new it's just built
in a very old sort of Romanticism style
it's that's one of wood for a lot of
this building this is very light I also
figured it just goes very well with the
very dark red color of the roof so yeah
I'm actually quite happy with how this
looks speaking of colors by the way I
totally forgot to mention but you can
probably say that I changed the colors
of the coaster I changed it more than
once actually changed it between the
time-lapse and the POV of the last video
as well for now I changed it into green
and purple which is a little bit less
interesting I do love the color scheme
as it was I just feel this fits much
better with the theme of the winter that
we have over here I just wanted to avoid
the color lights blue and white for all
I could because that would just
completely be gone in the landscape and
it's a pretty overused color for winter
themed coasters so instead I feel green
and dark purple is a pretty good way to
sort of hints at the the general cold
spectrum of colors but at the same time
not having it become too cliche and
interestingly I feel this color scheme
works super well as a tropical color
scheme as well
but the same goes for the color scheme
that I had earlier on I might try that
again as well and also the color scheme
is something that I am kind of a
perfectionist about I like to change
them like all the time so this might
change at some point in the future again
to maybe replace the green with a
slightly darker color but we'll see
anyway I wanted to get back to the
station here because the roof didn't
have anything to support it yet so I
wanted to make some simple trusses to
actually hold up the roof so these were
simple trusses to begin with just a
couple of lanterns and the basic
structure that you need to realistically
probably I don't have an engineering
degree this is generally how you can
build trusses to hold up the roof
basically and I guess that's alright but
it's nothing that's like very decorative
so after finishing these couple of
girders that I built over here I
actually wanted to revisit the trusses
and add a bit of decoration to it
because now it just kind of sticks out
that has a very simple part of an
otherwise a very detailed building
that's pretty much sugar coated at this
point also something that worked out
quite well was actually changing the
direction of the roof so to make some
slightly angled roofs make the building
a bit more asymmetrical and bit more
interesting that way I felt and that
turned out to be notes to Han I was
actually very afraid of this not working
out but it connects perfectly and that
should pretty much finish that so here I
went into the decorations for underneath
the trusses which are very similar to
the motifs that I really have at the top
of the roofs having repetition
throughout a building is of course super
important so I wanted to make sure that
these patterns kind of do reference like
the patterns which I have in the rest of
the building but at the same time are
used to decorate the trusses and make
them a bit more interesting than just
bare planks and just something that
holds up the structure of the roof
because just because something is like
necessary for structural purposes
doesn't mean that it can't be part of
the scenery as well so
I wanted to first get into some supports
and make something interesting out of
that's not just simple wooden pillars
but actually decorate them a little bit
and I believe that Christmas decoration
is a pinecone yeah that's what you call
them which fits the theme perfectly and
it's something which also fits the shape
of the pillar in quite a nice way it
kind of gives it a crown so that's
something that I wanted to do here and
then the pattern for the top beam is
just quite simple compared to the
patterns that I already have slightly
different but I feel like there's enough
repetition in there to at least keep it
all lights all part of the same building
and then I went into the Front's of the
facade here kind of give the building a
bronze because it didn't really have
anything that just speaks to the people
as you were walking here and this is
really the most important angle for the
building this is where you're gonna now
be walking into this side of the park if
this were a part of a different Clark
but in any case as you approach the
coaster this is the angle that you're
gonna look at the station from so I
definitely wanted to give the station
some weanie
capabilities from this area so it just
sort of opens up toward this part and
I'm not gonna do as much with the back I
definitely want to get back to it no pun
intended because you know I don't just
leave it behind but this was the most
important part so the back is
interesting because I actually went back
to the the Russian style of roof that I
hadn't tried yet because I was very
afraid of it and this point I was
already so far into the time-lapse
without you know even having finished
the building then I figured you know
[ __ ] it we're just gonna try it anyway
to make some of these very typical
Russian bell-shaped roofs I'm not
actually sure what the exact name for
them is but these have just modeled more
or less after the standard kind of roof
that you very often find it's something
then I didn't have in the building yet
and that just kind of felt bad and kind
of felt like something to make it look a
bit more Russian and this will also be a
pretty handy modular piece so I'll be
saving all of these things
and hopefully reusing them for the next
buildings meaning the hoods or the
transfer track or whatever else I'm
gonna add Oh actually I didn't speak
about the hut yet but I'm not gonna do
that yet so I'm gonna reuse these pieces
and hopefully the the future episode
should be going a little bit more
smoothly and a little bit more quick
because I basically had to make
everything from scratch in this episode
and that's really what most of the time
was being sunken into which makes it
quite tough because I I did put myself
on a deadline to come back to a couple
of comments that I got on the last video
this series does mean that I'm sort of
pushing my other series out of the way
because this takes a tremendous amount
of time and I I put myself in the
deadline of Christmas Eve if I want to
get the POV out before Christmas Eve the
current plan is to have four episodes of
this which means that there's a time
constraints but there is also sort of an
episode constraint I have to get enough
work done in every episode it's actually
deliver the end products by the time
that Christmas Eve has arrived and get a
POV video out for it which is pretty
time-consuming there are quite a few
hours that I need to sink in the into
the time lapse and the editing cinematic
shots and all that so we'll see how I
manage but basically the only reason
that I still have trusts then I can make
this is because this was just sort of
planned to be my most time-consuming
episode ever anyway because I need to
make everything from scratch and the
next ones will just take that already
built modular pieces maybe change them a
little bit but more or less just use
them as if they were in game pieces and
one of the reasons why I want to do
something like this is just kind of like
what I said at the beginning of the
video this is just such a unique theme
that I didn't want to try it with the
in-game pieces and just sort of make it
like it it sort of approaches the theme
but isn't entirely it's I just wanted to
go exactly for what I was looking for
which is why I'm making everything
custom and also it just kind of helps
make everything look unique I think
especially after thousands of players
play the game more and more
you see the same pieces over and over
again you're just gonna recognize them
and nothing's gonna stand out if you use
the same pieces and really in losing
pieces in different ways that they're
not supposed to or that nobody else has
done yet that's how I think you can make
some actually amazing creative unique
rides not to say that rides that don't
do it aren't good that's definitely not
the case it's just it's a way to make
something that has a much more lasting
impact I feel something that's more
timeless because it it's it's more close
to what your actual actual fantasy of
what you're building is than being
constricted by what the game actually
offers so at this point I have just
about kind of finished the cable for the
building started work on the transfer
track and little bit of scenery around
the coaster as well it's nothing too
interesting yet but that does give a
pretty good base for the rest of the
videos so I hope you guys enjoyed this
time-lapse in the next one I'll be
working on the little hood somewhere
finishing the transfer track and general
scenery around this area and hopefully
setting it all up so that in Episode
four I can finish the entire projects so
see you guys later